RIGHT. GOOD MORNING AFTERNOON.
WHATEVER TIME OF DAY IT IS.
WELCOME. TO THE AUGUST ELEVENTH
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE HEARING WE HAVE FORTY
FOUR BILLS CONSIDER THIS
AFTERNOON. I A NOTE THAT THERE
IS DEFINITELY AN ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM BUT WE ARE GOING TO
START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE. AND I
HOPE AND PRAY THAT SOME FOLKS
MAKE THEIR WAY TO. CREATE
QUORUM. WOOD M. YES I AM GET
THROUGH THEY THEY THEY GAVE ME
A LOT TO READ. SO I HAVE TO.
BUT WILL OF THIS BODY I WILL
READ OUT ALL THESE INSTRUCTIONS
THANK YOU TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VOEPEL WHO AT SOME POINT WILL
MAKE IT DOWN WITH THIS TODAY
BEFORE WE BEGIN I A FEW
HOUSEKEEPING NOTES THAT I'VE
BEEN ASKED TO COOPER. WORK
DISTANCE BETWEEN ONE ANOTHER
HEARING ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING. WE'RE ABLE TO
ONLY HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WATCHING PARTICIPATING
HEARING IN PERSON. WE ARE ALSO
REQUIRING THAT MASS BE WORN IN
PHYSICAL DISTANCING BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS.
PUBLIC WEATHER HERE IN THE ROOM
OR AT THE VIDEO CONFERENCING
SITE OUTSIDE. DO NOT HAVE A
MASK WE CAN PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU.
IF YOU CAN FOR WITNESS TEST
TODAY. FOR THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WE CAN ACCOMMODATE ONLY A
SMALL NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND STILL MAINTAIN
SIX FEET OF SPACE IN BETWEEN
ONE ANOTHER. THERE ARE DISTRICT
WILL DISEMPOWER CALLS FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ENTER AND LEAVE THE
CAPITAL IN THE HEARING
BUILDING. IN THE HEARING ROOM.
FOR ANY PRESENTED TO THE
COMMITTEE BY. AUTHOR WE WILL
ALLOW PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
TIME THE BILL IS HEARD. WE HAVE
WILL HAVE A TOTAL OF TWO
MINUTES IN SUPPORT IN TWO
MINUTES IN OPPOSITION. FOR ALL
OTHER BILLS WE WILL ACCEPT
PUBLIC COMMENT BEFORE THE CLOSE
OF THE HEARING THAT PUBLIC
COMMENT WILL JUST BE SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION. IN EITHER CASE HAS
THE- NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE.
IF YOU CAN EXIT THE HEARING
ROOM ONCE YOU ARE DONE
TESTIFYING OR RETURN YOUR SEATS
PLEASE DO SO. HE'S BE SURE TO
OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISTANCING
UPON LEAVING THE CAPITAL
INCLUDING LIMITING L. THERE
USED TO ONE PERSON AT A TIME.
FOR DIAL IN WITNESS. WE WILL
ALSO USE A MODERATE TELEPHONE
SERVICE TO ALLOW TESTIMONY ON A
BILL IF YOU'D LIKE TO TESTIFY
BY ON THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING. IS SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. THE ACCESS CODE IS.
SEVEN THREE TWO SIX TWO FOUR
TWO. AGAIN THE NUMBERS.
877-692-8957 IN THE ACCESS CODE
IS SEVEN THREE TWO TWO FOUR TWO
YOU CAN ALSO AND THIS NUMBER ON
IS THAT THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AS WELL AS
ON YOUR TV. IF YOU'RE CALLING
PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO IS THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOU'RE
TESTIFYING ON IS BEGINNING
THEIR BILL PRESENTATION. THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU THE INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO
BE PLACED IN THE QUEUE BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THAT BILL. YOU'RE CALLING
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL THE
BACKGROUND NOISES THIS INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCASTING YOUR SMART DEVICE
TO REDUCE DOWN DISTORTION. IF
YOU HAVE PROBLEMS WITH THE
MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU MAY
CALL THE COMMITTEE AT.
916-319-2081 STAFF WILL ATTEMPT
TO HELP YOU. ALSO ON THE PHONE
TODAY WE ARE. ON THE SCREEN
RIGHT BEHIND ME WITH MILLIONS
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WRITTEN NET PRESENT FINANCES
PERSPECTIVE IF THEY HAVE ONE.
SOME WITNESSES TODAY MADE USE
OF ONE OF OUR REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATIONS THE STATIONS ARE
LOCATED ON THE CAPITAL IN OTHER
LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT THE- IBM
COMMITTEE WILL IT. I ALSO WANT
KNOW THAT WE ACCEPT WRITTEN
TESTIMONY TO THE EMAIL SYSTEM
AND THROUGH THE POSTAL SERVICE
AS DESCRIBED ON THE
PREPARATIONS COMMITTEE WEBSITE
THANK YOU FOR BEARING WITH US
AS WE IMPLEMENT METHODS TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA. WILL ALSO. RISK OF
THE PUBLIC. CONCERN WE ALL
THESE. STILL NANOTECH PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. GONZALEZ
PRESIDENT BIGELOW. MARKON BLOOM
BONTA CALDERON YOUR OUR ALI
VOEPEL FOR DEEP EGGMAN FONG
GABRIEL GARCIA PETRIE-NORRIS
WORK RIVAS. ALL RIGHT WE CAN
ACTUALLY START ISRAEL COMMITTEE.
YEAH WE HAVE A MOTION BY DOCTOR
EGGMAN A SECOND BY MR BIGELOW-
THAT GETS OUT ON AN EIGHTY.
ROLL CALL WOULD YOU TO READ THE
CONSENT CALENDAR HEALTH
SECRETARY. IF YOU'RE NOT NEXT
TO ME CONSENT. SB EIGHT SIXTY
NINE NINE EIGHTEEN BUDGET
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENT
ORGANIZATION. SB TEN THIRTY
COMMITTEE ON HOUSING. SB EIGHT
HUNDRED NINETY THREE SB.
387-025-8712 THIRTY ONE IN
TWELVE SEVENTY SIX CONSECUTIVE.
THANK YOU. AT AGAIN GETS OUT ON
A ROLL CALL. WITH THAT TOO I
SEE ANY AUTHORS OUT MISS LEYVA.
MISLAID IS PRESENTING ON SB
THREE ONE TWO IT ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR WITH THAT I WILL
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
DON'T THANK YOU YOU'RE WELCOME
LIKE THAT IBM ARE GONNA GO
AHEAD AND GO TO THE PHONES- IT
LOOKS LIKE YOUR WITNESS. WE'RE
LOOKING FOR JANET. I HERE. IT
SHAKESPEARE OK THANK. A ADDED
AFTER MATTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THE S. UP. COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
JAY NEW AND BY HERE BROKE
CANCER PER PARTNERS WHAT THE
NGOS THE BEST THE TWO. I I'M
AVAILABLE THE ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU HAVE BUT SINCE YOU'VE
MOVED TO BUILD THE YOU MIGHT
NOT ANY I BE. I WANTED TO THANK
THEM LEYVA FOR HER SUPPORT OF
THIS BELL I'M IN WITH THAT
LEGISLATIVE JOURNEY THE BILL
HAS FOR EIGHTY NINE PROP ORG.
BUSINESSES RANGING FROM THE
AMERICAN LONG AND SO. UNILEVER
EFFECT LARGEST CAUSE. NOT IN
FACT NOR IS IT ANTI USINESS
THERE ARE HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS
OF COSMETIC COMPANIES ALREADY.
AND FULLY DISCLOSING FRAGRANCE
INGREDIENTS. AT. THE CLOSURE IS
NOT ONLY POSSIBLE IT'S PROPER
BE THAT'S WHY YOU DO WANT. AND
GREATER FINANCIAL THERE ARE
LINKS. SOME OF THE CAMERA IN
PROFESSIONAL WANT TO PEOPLE.
THAT THE LONGER AND HE WORK.
ONE ONCE AGAIN THE LEADING THE
NATION IN TERMS OF PROTECTING
VULNERABLE POPULATION AND IN
TERMS OF SETTING A HIGH BAR FOR
INGREDIENT TRANSPARENCY NOT
ONLY FOR CALIFORNIA. BUT FOR
KIDS. WITH THE CLASSIC ON.
THANK YOU THANK YOU KNOW
THERE'S A MOTION BY DR ED MAN
THERE'S A SECOND BY MISS
CARILLO- ANYONE LISTENING FOR
FUTURE BILLS THIS IS THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WHICH
MEANS TEST SHOULD BE TO JUST.
PULLING OUT THE SO WE CAN SEE
THAT IN THE FUTURE OUR ON JUST.
IT IS. A AT THE BASE OF THE
BILL DO I HAVE ANY. I HAVE ONE
YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION
THERE'S ANY AND THAT'S ALL
WE'RE LOOKING FOR AND THAT IS
FOR THE BILL.
AT WE CAN HEAR
YOU JUST CAN STATE YOUR NAME
THE ORGANIZATION IF YOU HAVE
ONE IN YOUR POSITION ON THE
BILL. THANK YOU DID YOU. THANK
YOU WITHOUT. WELL WE THANK YOU
THAT IS ALL THE TESTIMONY THAT
WE'RE TAKING OUR ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WITH AT WE
GO TO- TESTIMONY ARE ANY
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE DO WE HAVE
ANY SUPPORTERS OF SB THREE ONE
TWO. THANK YOU MA'AM F YOU DO
WISH TO SHARE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THERE ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
AT THIS TIME. AGAIN SUPPORT FOR
S. B. THREE ONE TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AND BE JUST
A MOMENT. WE DO HAVE ONE LINE.
LIKE TO SHARE THEIR POSITION
APPLYING TWENTY EIGHT TO EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND YOUR MEMBERS
PERSONAL GET OFF ON THE HALF OF
THE NATIONAL ACTION COUNCIL AND
CALIFORNIA PRODUCT. CAMPBELL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THAT WAS IT FOR SUPPORTERS IF
THERE ARE CORRECT. AND I ASSUME
THERE IS NOBODY OUTSIDE. WELL
THEY JUST POP UP ON THE SCREEN
DOES ANYONE KNOW HOW I WILL BE
INFORMED OKAY THERE'S NOBODY
OUTSIDE- WITHOUT WILL GO TO ANY
OPPOSITION WOULD ANYBODY LIKE
TO STATE THEIR OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL ANYBODY IN THE- BUILT
IN. NOW I DON'T SEE ANYONE ON
THE SCREENS AND THE PHONES IS
THERE ANYBODY OPPOSED TO SB
THREE TWELVE. LIKE TO SHARE
YOUR POSITION OF OPPOSITION THE
S. B. THREE ONE TWO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD THAT'S ONE
ZERO PLEASE. WARNING QUEUE AT
THIS TIME MANAGER. THANK YOU-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. IS
MISSING NOW THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- REALLY YEAH AND WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
FINANCE HAS NO POSITION ON THIS
BILL WE DO KNOW THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
ESTIMATES BECAUSE OF TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
IN THE FIRST YEAR AND FIFTY TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS DROUGHT ON THE
ON GOING. I MEAN FOR NOTED.
THIS WILL BE REQUIRED OF THIS
BILL. GREAT THANK YOU SEE NO
DISCUSSION I SAW A MOTION AND A
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
MISLAID REQUEST FOR QUOTE THAT
GETS OUT ON AN EIGHT TWELVE MR
BIG MISTER FOR NOT VERY THANK
YOU OFTEN THINK ABOUT CHAIR
THANK MEMBERS WONDER. MISTER
MINING. SB ELEVEN- TO MR MINE
IS THE ONLY OTHER BILL WE HAVE.
HERE TODAY SO THAT IS NOT TRUE.
THAT'S WHAT I OUT. SORRY THAT
TIME WE HAVE TO TESTIMONY FOR
I'M SORRY. MR ARCHULETA IF HE
IS IN THE BUILDING IN. MARLENE
OR MISTER AMBERG. XENON CAN WE
GO AHEAD AND READ THE LIST OF
BILLS THAT ARE TO THE SUSPENSE
FILE. JERRY. SB. 1-156-934-7958.
003-912-1409 922-811-7347 ONE
SIX. THIRTY THREE FIFTEEN AND
SIX. SEVEN OH THREE TWELVE
FIFTY NINE THIRTEEN FORTY ONE
NINE SEVENTY THREE FOURTEEN THE.
1-729-914-9210. EIGHTY FIVE
FIVE NINETY SIX ELEVEN SEVENTY
FIVE TWELVE TWENTY AND ELEVEN
THIRTY. MISTER MARK ARE HEADED
TO THE SUSPENSE CALENDAR IF YOU
WERE PLANNING TO SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO WHEN
THOSE BILLS THOSE BILLS HAVE.
THERE IS INDICATION FOR THIS
BILL HAVE BEEN WAIVED BY THE
AUTHOR AND SO AT THE END OF
TODAY'S HEARING YOU MAY STATE
YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION AND-
THAT YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE ON
THAT LIST IF YOU WANT TO THERE
WILL BE NO TEST. COUNTY I'M I
OR I'M IS I'M ASSUMING. WE'LL
START WITH THAT YOU HAVE TO
BILLS. THAT WE'RE HEARING TODAY
YES IN THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
WE'LL START WITH SENATE BILL
ELEVEN OH TWO. ASKGANESHA ME A
MOTION BY MISS CURRY IN A-
SECOND BY A DOCTOR COURT. THANK
YOU. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS LAST
YEAR SLIGHTLY MORE THAN TWENTY
THREE THOUSAND FOREIGN FARM
WORKERS WERE PORTED BY ROUGHLY
ONE HUNDRED CALIFORNIA GROWERS
AND FARM LABOR CONTRACTORS
UNDER THE H. TWO A. FEDERAL
VISA PROGRAM. THIS NUMBER HAS
BEEN INCREASED ANNUALLY.
MEMBERS THIS BILL PROVIDES
NOTICE TO THOSE H. TWO A. GUEST
WORKERS PROVIDES INFORMATION
ABOUT ANY CURRENT DECLARATION
OF EMERGENCY INCLUDING COVERT
OR WILDFIRE. AND IT PROVIDES
GUEST WORKERS WITH SPECIFIC
INFORMATION ABOUT CALIFORNIA
LABOR LAWS AND PROTECTIONS
INCLUDING WAY TREATS OVERTIME
PAY IT'S SET. IN SPANISH OR
ENGLISH AS CHOIR MEMBERS I
WOULD URGE YOUR SUPPORT AND I
VOTE- I HAVE TODAY REMOTELY TWO
WITNESSES SENT RICE AND MARK
SHOCKED WITH CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT OF. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
THIS IS MARK SHOCKER CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION WE'RE SPONSORING THE
BILL- LIKE OTHER RURAL LEGAL
SERVICES PROGRAMS WE DIRECT YOU
CAN ENGAGE IN A FARMWORKERS FOR
MANY YEARS PRIOR READ MEDICAID.
AFTER THE PROGRAM. WE REPRESENT
THE BASIC AWAY FAR. PENDING
THAT BASE INVOLVING OTHERS. BY
A OF CALIFORNIA LAW BY EACH TO
FOR OUR AT FIVE LABOR. ALTHOUGH
ADMINISTERED LARGELY BY THE
UNITED STATES START. OF LABOR
U. S. B. O. L. HAS A POOR
RECORD OF PROTECTING BOTH
WORKERS IN THIS CAMP EVEN. SHOP
MORE FOR H. TWO. HELLO THAT
INCLUDES JOB TERMS VIOLATE
STATE LAW COLLECTING THAT
MONNING SAID S. B. ELEVEN OH
TWO TOGETHER TO WORKERS WERE NO
BY THE PROVIDER TO EIGHTY A
PART AND ON THEIR FIRST OF WORK
IN OF SEVERAL DOES HE
CALIFORNIA WILL HELP TAKE. LAWS
AS NOW NOT. HAVE MADE. BEFORE
WE GO THE SECOND WITNESS- SINCE
MY PHONE HAS BLOWN UP I'M
EXCITED TO SAY WE HAVE A VICE
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE COMING
OUT OF CALIFORNIA LET THE GAMES
BEGIN COMBAT. TO S. THE THAT
WILL TAKE WITNESS. I'M HAPPY
NINE THEM MY NAME CYNTHIA I'M A
PAL GIRL LEGAL WITH WE PROVIDE
LEGAL SERVICES OKAY THROUGHOUT
WITH AN AYE TIME TO COMPLY
LEGAL AND- INCLUDING A LABOR.
THE WHAT COULD HAVE BEEN
VIOLATED AS DESCRIBED BY SOME
NUMBER. THIS OPEN BASICALLY
WERE BY THAT KNOW THEY RIGHT IT
ALSO PROTECTS DOMESTIC WHO
MIGHT HAVE BEEN OUT BECAUSE
THEY FEAR THEY BE. WITH AN
EXTREMELY WORK ON THAT'S NOT NO
ENOUGH CANNOT MAKE DEMAND. BUT
LACKS THE- DAYS EXCELLENT WORK
WITH A COULD. BY EMPLOYER OKAY
WHEN AND GET INTO THE COUNTRY
THEY- WHERE THEY WHERE WHO
DON'T MAKE. AND STATE YOU.
WORKER AND INTERVENTIONS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU- AFTER
THOSE TWO WE NOW ARE JUST GOING
TO MOVE TO INDIVIDUALS WHO- ARE
VOICING THEIR SUPPORT WILL
START HERE IN THE GALLERY I
MEAN NOBODY WE DO HAVE A WORK
OKAY SOMEBODY PLEASE. JUST YOUR
NAME AND ORGANIZATION AND
OBVIOUSLY YOUR VISIT PART.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU IS THERE
ARE THERE ANYBODY OUTSIDE I
DON'T SEE ANYBODY OUTSIDE WILL
GO HEAD OF THE PHONES- COLORS
IN SUPPORT OF WE COULD OPEN UP
OUTLINES. SB THREE ONLY. IF
YOU. IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THE TIME. AGAIN ONE ZERO IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
AT THE TIME WE DO HAVE TWO THAT
ARE IN SUPPORT. FIVE THIRTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON
REBECCA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THE NEXT TO GO TO NUMBER THIRTY
NINE THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GIRLFRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIANS
CONSTRUCT THE COURT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WITH THAT WE WILL
MOVE TO ANY OPPOSITION ANYBODY
FIRST HERE IN THE GALLERY OUT
FIRST WE HAVE WHICH I DON'T
HAVE A LIST OF WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SO I ASSUME THEY
WOULD BE GALLERY. NO OPPOSITE.
NOTHING ON THE- CAN WE GO TO
FOR ANY COLOR IN OFFICE. TO
ELEVEN TWO. AND IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION OF ELEVEN OH TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE AT THIS TIME.
AGAIN ONE ZERO IF YOU'RE
OPPOSITION. WE DO HAVE ONE IN
OPPOSITION- JUST TAKE A MOMENT.
AND WE'LL GO O NUMBER THIRTY
THREE NUMBER THIRTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN GOOD AFTERNOON
MATTHEW ALONG WITH WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL BECAUSE IT
ACTUALLY CONTABILIDAD ME ABOUT
THAT THE TRAVEL TIME VISION AND
THE PROVISION WITH EMPLOYER
PROVIDED HOUSING THE. I DON'T
THAT CHANGES. IT'S BLOOD WE
WERE OPPOSED TO THE- THANK YOU
WILL NOW GO. ANY STATED
OPPOSITE. NAME ORGAN AND IS THE
ON THE PHONES. OF THE NEXT WILL
GO TO NUMBER THIRTY FOUR-
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TRANSPARENT
WITH CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THANK YOUNG. AT THE TIME WE
HAVE NO FURTHER IN Q. ON THE
PHONES PLEASE GET THAT. I'M
SORRY I HAVE A HARD TIME
SOMETIMES YOU'RE NOT I'M
WITHOUT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WE HAVE POSITION. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR NOTED OF FINANCE
DOES NOT HAVE A POSITION WE DO
NOTE THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS AND
EMPLOYMENT OF DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT REPORT NO FISCAL
IMPACT AS A RESULT OF. BILL
GREAT. WOULD YOU. YES THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS- JUST A
BRIEF COMMENT BEFORE YOU POST
I'M SORRY DR COURT DOES HAVE
OKAY THANK YOU. SENATOR COULD
YOU SPEAK TO THE OPPOSITION
CLOSE- THEY SAID THAT SOME OF
THESE REGULATIONS REDUNDANT ARE
THEY REALLY REDUNDANT THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO THAT QUESTION SOME
OF THE REGULATIONS. THIS WOULD
MAKE REDUNDANT REPORTING AT THE
EMPLOYER CAN COMBINE THE
FEDERALLY REQUIRED NOTICE WITH
STATE THEY ARE NOT IDENTICAL
OUR STATE HAS STRONGER LABOR
LAWS SOME PROTECTION THAT WOULD
BE PART THIS NOTICE I'D ALSO IN
MY CLOTHES LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE.
OPPOSITION AND THE TRAVEL
TIME- COMPONENT OF THIS- THE
VAST MAJORITY OVER 95% MAYBE
99% OF THE COST WORKERS H. TWO
A. GUEST WORKERS THAT THIS BILL
GOES TO. OUR BROUGHT BY
EMPLOYER HOUSE BY THE EMPLOYER
IN TRANSPORTED BY THE EMPLOYER.
THE DEBATE IN THE COURTS ABOUT
TRAVEL TIME HAS RELATED TO
WHETHER THE WORKER. HAS THE
OPTION OF TAKING THEIR OWN B.
BALL OR THE OP GET ON THE BUS
THIS CASE EXERCISE NOT. THEIR
OWN. THE NOT ENTITLED TO TRAVEL
H. TWO A. WORKERS FRIEND BY DE
ARE WORKERS TRANSPORTED AND HOW
BY THE END. THIS BILL SIMPLY.
EXISTING LAW ABOUT THE RIGHT TO
TRAVEL TO I RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU- WITH
THAT IN SEE NO OTHER COMMENTS-
THAT GETS OUT ON A. B. ROLL
CALL THANK YOU. YOUR SECOND
BILL SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR
ALSO ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION I HAVE A MOTION.
BY MISS CARILLO IN A SECOND I
CORK. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS REAL QUICKLY THIS BILL
HAS NO OPPOSITION ON FILE IT
DOES- PROVIDE FOR THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER TO PROVIDE
REPRESENTATION IN AN
ARBITRATION HEARING KEEPING
PARTIES OUT OF THE COURTS IN
THE INTEREST I BELIEVE OF BOTH
EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES I WOULD
URGE I VOTE. THANK YOU- ARE
THERE ANY SPEAKERS HERE ON THE
LINE TO BE A WITNESSES I DON'T
THINK WE HAVE WITNESSES ON THIS
BILL DO WE OKAY ARE THERE ANY
SPEAKERS IN THE GALLERY IN
SUPPORT. C. NINE ANY SPEAKERS
OUTSIDE. I THINK NOT OF ANY
SPEAKERS ON THE PHONE OUR
ANYBODY WANT TO REGISTER THEIR
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE FOR. SB
JUST CROSSED IT OUT. THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR THANK YOU. GERMAN
ON THE PHONE LINE IF YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
THIS TIME AGAIN ONE ZERO IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT. AT THE TIME WE
HAVE KNOWN IN OUR QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU- SEEN THOSE
BODY IN SUPPORT ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION ANYBODY OPPOSITION
HERE IN THE GALLERY SCENE NINE.
I THINK THAT ON THE TV IS THERE
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONES. AND IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION THE PHONE LINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN
ONE ZERO HERE IN OPPOSITION. AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE CONTINUE. SEE
NOBODY IN SUPPORT NOBODY IN
OPPOSITION DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE GIVE A PILE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HAS NO POSITION ON THIS
BILL- WE DO NOT THAT WHILE THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS ESTIMATES THE COSTS
RELATED TO THIS BILL ARE
AFFORDABLE WITH EXISTING RESORT
IS. AN ARBITRARY IS LABOR
INTENSIVE AND MORE COMPLEX AND
TIME THAT ADMINISTRATIVE
HEARING THERE FOR THEIR BE COST
PRESSURE. CURRENTLY ON BUT
CIGNA SO DEPENDING ON VARIOUS.
LAST WEEK THE MEDIA COST
PRESSURES A RESULT OF MORE
EMPLOYEES SUBJECT TO MANDATORY
ARBITRATION. ALL RIGHT WITH
THAT I SEE NO QUESTIONS WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
JUST BRIEFLY I WOULD NINE VOTE
IN AND WE'RE JUNE ALTER WHERE
YOU WERE. IN FRONT ASSEMBLY
OPERATIONS WHEN HE LEARNED OF
THE SELECT OF PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE BIDEN OF KAMILLA
HARRIS AS HIS VICE PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE WITH THAT MADAM CHAIR
THANK OU- DERIVE A- THANK YOU
SIR THAT GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL
CALL. MISTER AMBER GUY FIERI
YOUR NEXT. YOU WILL BE
PRESENTING ON SB NINE SEVENTY
ENJOY THE DO PASSED THE
MEDICATION. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS SB NINE.
SEVEN AND MY DOCTOR QUIRK IN
THIS IF I MISSED. BOB THANK YOU
YOU WILL THE PRIMARY IN NON
PRESS YEARS JUNE TO GO. FOR
TWENTY TWENTY TO BECAUSE THIS
THE- OR DO NOT VOTE. THANK YOU
ARE THERE'S- WHERE LOOK UP IN
THE GALLERY. I SEE NO A SUPPORT.
ON. EIGHT NOTHING GOING ON IN
THE SCREENS BEHIND ARE THERE
BECAUSE IN SOME OF MR I SB.
NINE SEVEN. HILLARY GERMAN THE
PHONE PLEASED ONE HERE IN
SUPPORT. AGAIN WHY ZERO IF ARE
IN. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NOBODY
IN SUPPORT PLEASE CONTINUE
THANK YOU WILL GO TO OPPOSITION
IS THERE ANYBODY IN THE GALLERY
IN OPPOSITION. SEEN NONE I SEE
NOBODY ON THE SCREENS BEHIND ME
SO WITH THAT WE'LL GO TO THE
PHONES IS THERE ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB NINE SEVEN.
AND NOW YOU'RE IN OFFICE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO
IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION. AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NONE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE CONTINUE.
THANK YOU- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THANK YOU ARMINA
FINANCE HAS NO POSITION ON THIS
BILL WE DO KNOW THE SECRETARY
OF STATE INDICATES THE BILL
RESULT WILL RESULT IN NO
ADDITIONAL COST TO THE
DEPARTMENT. THANK WITH FAT.
MISTER BERG- GINGIVAL AND THAT
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL WITH MR
VOEPEL VOTING NOW THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NOW LOOKS LIKE WE
HAVE ONE MORE BILL ARCHER. SB
NINE OH FIVE IT WAS PULLED FROM
CONSENT I HAVE SOMEBODY.
ALERTED THEIR OFFICE. THE CHECK
I MISS ARCHULETA.
THERE'S ONLY
BEEN ONE NO THERE'S BEEN TWO
WOMEN VICE PRESIDENTIAL NOMINEE
RIGHT. INTERFERENCE NOT NEVER
ONE. FIFTY HISTORY. YEAH
MONDALE FERRARO.
NOW. I DON'T
NEED OR TWO I WAS JUST
WONDERING IF YOU COULD GET OUT
OF.FIVE MR ARCHULETA BE GREAT
IF YOU COME IN ABOUT A MINUTE
TO THE FALLEN TROUBLE. HE IS ON
HIS WAY. THANK YOU OFFER
WAITING. DOING WHAT WE CAN. WE
CAN'T. IF ANYBODY IN THE
GALLERY WANTS TO- WE CAN GO
AHEAD AND ALLOW SOMEBODY TO SAY
IF THEY'RE HERE TO SHOW THEIR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO A BILL
THAT HAS ALREADY BEEN MOVED TO
THIS. YOU CAN DO THAT I TRIED
TO CANCEL BUT. GOOD AFTERNOON-
ADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CAPPING LINES
REPRESENTING SAFARI CLUB
INTERNATIONAL OUTDOOR
SPORTSMAN'S COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA
SPORTSMEN'S LOBBY IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
FIVE YEAH CONNIE WITHIN SPECIES
PUT OF THE BILL. LIKE TO
REGISTERS. FIRST MR ARE LET US
S. B. L. FIFTH SIX BIOPIC.
WASTE HAULER COUNTS THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THAT'S EXACTLY HOW
DONE. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
ALEX TAURUS WAS THREE SIXTY
HERE TO REGISTER SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF VETERANS SERVICE
AGENCIES IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
EIGHT OH THREE BELL AND ALSO ON
BEHALF OF UP FOR GROWTH
ACTUALLY CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
OF SB TEN EIGHTY FIVE SKINNER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ROY
GRIFFITHS BECOME BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION I'M ALSO HERE TODAY
IN IN IN IT'S JUST OF- TIME TO
REPRESENT NUMEROUS OTHER GROUPS
I'D LIKE TO LIST WERE IN
OPPOSITION TO. SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE AND SB NINE
FOURTEEN. IN ADDITION THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE. SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF GUNNERS CALIFORNIA.
THE UNIT A- THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OCK MOUNT NORTH.
CALL CHAPTER THE WHILE SHE
FOUND. CALIFORNIA BOTH HUNDREDS
OF. AND WHILE BETTER.
CALIFORNIA HOUSE FOR CON. TO
APPRECIATION WHAT INSTALLED. A
NUMBER OTHER. WILDLIFE CONSERVE.
OR THANK. YOU THANK. CAN GALA
IN SUPPORT POSITION TO ANY THAT
WAS MY ASSIST STYLE. SEEN WE
CAN GO TO THE FOR AND SEE IF
ANY WANTS TO READ SO ON. JUST
YOUR NAME IN THE BILL AND THAT
YOUR NAME YOUR TITLE IN THE
BILL. TO ANY BILL THAT HAS BEEN
MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE FILE.
OPERATOR LA LLAMAN KID LIKE TO
VOICE SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AGAIN ONE ZERO FOUR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. ONCE
AGAIN ONE ZERO CURRENT OR
OPPOSITION OF ANY BILL. WE DO
HAVE A FEW IN Q. THAT JUST TAKE
A MOMENT OKAY.
AND THE FIRST
PERSON WILL MOVE TO IS NOT-
LINE SEVENTEEN LINE SEVENTEEN
IF YOU ARE OPEN. HI THIS IS
JUDY VANCOUVER HELLO AND I AM
THE FOUNDER AND PRESIDENT OF
SOCIAL COMPASSION IN
LEGISLATION WE ARE THE FATHER
OF S. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I ON THE
NEXT MOVES TO JUST A REMINDER
THESE ARE JUST FOR ANY BILL
THAT HAS BEEN MOVED TO THE
SUSPENSE SO YOU MIGHT WANT TO
TELL US WHICH BILL IT IS I
ASSUME THAT THAT WAS FOR THE
HENRY STERN- TELL THAT THERE
WAS OPPOSITION TO. THAT SINCE
THEY WERE THE SPONSOR. NEXT
WILL MOVE TO NUMBER THIRTEEN
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS NICHOLAS DOCKET I AM
REPRESENTING PIECE PER ANIMAL
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF B. ELEVEN
SEVEN FIVE. THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE FORTY SIX
FORTY SIX YOUR LINES OPEN. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS GARY
BRENNAN ON THE PRESIDENT OF SAN
DIEGO COUNTY WILDLIFE
FEDERATION CALLING IN DAY TO
DISPAR STRAW APPLE. TO SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT WILL BE NUMBER
FORTY SEVEN NUMBER FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HELLO
CRISTINA KARENGE FOR ANIMAL
DEFENDERS INTERNATIONAL IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT TO BE LINED TWENTY
THREE TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS GREGORY
KRAMER ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA. IN SUPPORT
OF THE FOLLOWING BILLS SENATE
BILL FIVE NINETY SIX STERN
SEVEN THREE NINE STERN. SEVEN
NINE FIVE BELL EIGHT OH THREE
BELL NINE SEVEN TWO SKINNER.
TEN EIGHTY FIVE SKINNER AND
SENATE BILL TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN
DROPS SO THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT WE CAN GO TO NUMBER
FORTY THREE LINE FORTY THREE
YOUR OPEN. THANK YOU SERVICE
DEMOCRAT ON THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
SOUTH SACRAMENTO CHECK VERY
CALIFORNIA. AND ALSO MEMBER IN
STRONG OFFICE TO NA ONE. HEY S.
B. ONE SEVEN FIVE THANK YOU.
THE NEXT WILL BE A LINE TWENTY
ONE TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
WITH YOU FIGURE OUT WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA GROCERS ASSOCIATION.
AND OPPOSITION TO THE FOLLOWING
THOSE SB SEVENTY THREE AND AT
THE POINT NINE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND THEN NEXT WEEK GO TO
LINE TWENTY FIVE LINE TWENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI SHANTI
PRASAD WOULD CALIFORNIA'S. OF
FOOD BANKS IN SUPPORT OF BOTH
SB FORTINO NINE AND S. B.
ELEVEN OH THREE THANK YOU. NEXA
THE NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN NUMBER
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINES OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I'M NOT
WRONG TO SHUDDER INTO SHELTER
BUYING I JUST IN SOME OF S. B.
O. SEVEN ON BEHALF OF THE MAKES
UNITED STATES AND CAL. THE NEXT
TO BE LINE FORTY EIGHT LINE
FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS DANIELLE KATZ THE
DIRECTOR PETE UP PEOPLE FOR THE
ETHICAL TREATMENT OF ANIMALS.
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF OUR SIX
HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND MEMBERS
AND SUPPORTERS IN CALIFORNIA WE
URGE YOU TO VOTE YES ON AT
ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE THANK YOU.
FOR THEIR. MR OPERATOR. ALL
RIGHT I SEE MR ARCHULETA IS
HERE. WE JUST. OKAY SORRY WE'RE
GONNA GONNA RESEARCH WHAT IS
BILL THEN SB EIGHT NINE OH I
ENJOY TO DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
WE HAVE A BY MISS CARILLO AND-
AT. SECOND BY DOCTOR THANK YOU
MISTER LED A. MAYBE STATEMENT
PRESENT YEP YOU HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND ALREADY THANK YOU SO
MUCH MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS I'M
HERE TO PRESENT SENATE BILL
NINE OH FIVE BACKGROUND CHECKS
SECURITY A- CALIFORNIA ALLOWS
ORGANIZATIONS TO REQUEST ALL.
OF AN APPLICANT'S RECORDS OF
CONVICTIONS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. IF THE
APPLICANT WOULD HAVE
SUPERVISORY OR DISCIPLINARY
POWER OVER A MINOR OR ANOTHER
IN THEIR CARE THIS MEASURE. IS
A PRUDENT STEP IN ENSURING. THE
SAFETY OF MINE. OTHER BONTA.
CAN BE EXPLOITED TO DIVULGE THE
LOWER OF A- INTO. THAT APPLYING
TO VOLUNTEER IN THEIR COMMUNITY.
THE FEAR OF PERSONAL
INFORMATION BEING. HAS CREATED
A CHILLING EFFECT ON THE
VOLUNTEER EFFORTS OF
ORGANIZATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
INDIVIDUALS ARE AFRAID OF
VOLUNTEERING AND CONTRIBUTING
TO THEIR COMMUNITIES FOR FEAR
OF THE PRIVACY BEING BREACHED
BY FEDERAL ENTITIES. DURING
THIS CALL WAS NINETEEN CRISIS
WE NEED VOLUNTEERS MORE THAN
EVER. ESPECIALLY NOW PEOPLE
SHOULD NOT BE HELD BACK BY
PROCEDURE FOR CONTRIBUTING TO
THE COMMUNITY. SENATE BILL NINE
OH FIVE PROTECT THE PRIVACY OF
CALIFORNIANS BY NO LONGER
REQUIRING THE RESIDENT ADDRESS
ON THE BACKGROUND CHECK. BYE
NOT REQUIRED THAT READ THE
ADDRESS ON THE BACKGROUND
CHECK. WE CAN PROVIDE
ASSURANCES TO INDIVIDUALS THAT
THEY CAN VOLUNTEER IN THE
COMMUNITIES WITHOUT RISKING AND
COMPROMISING THE SAFETY AND
SECURITY OF THEMSELVES OR THEIR
FAMILIES. THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS IN
SUPPORT. ALFA A CATHOLIC
CONFERENCE IS IN SUPPORT THERE
IS NO KNOWN OPPOSITION. AND IT
WILL NOT INCUR ANY COSTS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU INSTRUCTION
LADDA AS- A MINUTE THERE ARE
NO. WITNESSES AND SO I WILL ASK
ANYONE THE GALLERY THAT
EXPRESSED SUPPORT. C. NINE
ANYONE OUTSIDE I SEE NOBODY
OUTSIDE IS THERE ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE THAT WISH TO EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT FOR SB NINE OH
FIVE. GET HER SUPPORT THE PRESS
ONE THANK YOU. FIRST RETURNED
TO LINE OF FOUR NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD PROVIDERS DON'T. DELAYED
FOR NINETY MIGHT GET YOUR LINE
MUTED. I APOLOGIZE YOU THAT THE
PHONE BY LAW IN. OVER MYSELF
AND CALL THE AND GIVE YOU.
THANK YOU. AND AGAIN PLEASE
PRESS. ONE ZERO FOUR SIX. NEXT
WE TURN TO LINE OUT TO ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR IS OPEN.
AGAIN JUST FOR NINE ZERO FIVE
IN SUPPORT- WOULD NEXT LINE OF
FOUR FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
TRAINEESHIP. THANK YOU. AND
NEXT RETURNED TO LINE UP FIVE
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS CARLENE ELLIS I WAS ACTUALLY
IN THE QUEUE FOR THE LAST ONE
AT THREE ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE I
AM A MEMBER OF THE SOUTH
SACRAMENTO- CALIFORNIA RIGHT
POLITICAL DIVISION THE NATIONALRIFLE ASSOCIATION.
INTERNATIONAL DEFENSIVE PISTOL
ASSOCIATION SACRAMENTO
DEFENSIVE PISTOL SHOOTERS AND
THE WHOLE FROM SHOOTING CLUB
AND I'LL BE HAPPY OVER FIVE
MILLION MEMBERS WE WOULD LIKE
TO STRONGLY OPPOSE SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE THANK YOU SB NINE.
OKAY AGAIN TERM IS FOR SUPPORT
OKAY. AND IT'S FOR A DIFFERENT
BILL AND I DO APOLOGIZE THIS IS
OUR EFFORT TO GO BACK AND FORTH
BECAUSE WE'RE WAITING ON MR
GILLETTE AT. RIGHT NOW IF YOU
HAVE CALLED IN AND YOU'RE
WAITING FOR US SUSPENSE ITEM.
I'M JUST REGISTER YOUR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION IF YOU CAN HANG UP
THE PHONE. AND CALL BACK WHILE
WE FINISH THE REGULAR ORDER
WHICH IS MR ARCHER LETTUCE SB
NINE OH FIVE. IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO SB
NINE OH FIVE. PLEASE STAY ON
THE LINE. WE ARE TAKING THOSE
CURRENTLY IN SUPPORT ONLY SB
NINE OH FIVE IF YOU ARE NOT. ON
THE LINE FOR SB NINE TO FIVE
PLEASE HANG UP YOUR PHONE. GO
AHEAD MR OPERATOR. THANK YOU
AND NEXT RETURN TO THE LINE UP
FOR TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. FORTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. NO
RESPONSE WE WILL PLAN OUR
CHURCHILL LINE FIVE TWO. FIVE
TWO YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WITH NO
RESPONSE DOWN WE WILL CHARGE
THE LINE FIVE SEVEN. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MR FOR IT SEEMS THAT
PEOPLE HAVE TAKEN MY WARNING
AND HUNG UP SO I DON'T KNOW IF
THERE'S A WAY TO. SPEED THROUGH
THESE.
JUST ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
WE DO HAVE ONE NOW AND IT'S
FROM LINE SEVEN ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THERE LOOK AT THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION- WANTED
TO WEIGH IN ON SEVENTY EIGHT OH
THREE BALANCE SUPPORT SB TWELVE
FIFTY NINE FURTADO ALSO IN
SUPPORT RIGHT NOW WE ARE ONLY
ON SB NINE OH FIVE THANK YOU WE
REGISTER YOUR SUPPORT FOR THOSE
BILLS BUT SB NINE OF. FIVE NO
FURTHER IN Q. OKAY CAN WE GO ON
TO OPPOSITION FOR SB NINE OH
FIVE. JENNIFER OPPOSITION FOR
NINE OH FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO CHECK OUT AFTER THE
Q. GET FOR OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THAT'S ZERO. AND WE
HAVE NO WHAT UP AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU- DEPARTMENT
OR IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION AND.
HERE IN THE GALLERY. C. NINE ON
THE SCREENS WILL GO TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
HAS NO POSITION ON THIS BILL
AND WE KNOW THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE INDICATES THE COSTS ARE
MINOR AND OBSERVABLE FROM THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. I WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE MY SEARCH LED IN THE
SOMEBODY HAS A QUESTION I SEE
NONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU. THAT BILL. GETS OUT ON A
B. ROLL CALL WITH MISS PETRI
NORRIS NOT VOTING. THANK YOU.
STARCH LETTER THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT MR OPERATOR IF WE CAN GO
BACK AGAIN AND I'M SORRY FOR
CONFUSING PEOPLE IT NOW IF YOU
CALLED IN. WE'RE GOING TO GO TO.
MR ACTUALLY DID YOU HAVE
ANOTHER BILL. I KNOW OKAY SO
MEDICARE- WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACK TO PUBLIC COMMENT AND SO
WE WILL GO BACK TO THE PHONE
LINES FOR ANY COMMENT ON A BILL
THAT WAS MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE
FILE IF YOU HAVEN'T ALREADY
REGISTER YOUR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. FEEL FREE- TO IT TO
CALL THIS TIME. AND AGAIN ARE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO IF
YOU'D LIKE TO ADD TO THE QUEUE.
AT FIRST WE TURN TO THE LINE OF
FOUR NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU THAT AFTERNOON THAT
ENSURES THAT THE NOT A NOT LIKE
HOW PUBLIC AFFAIRS CALLING- FOR
A COUPLE OF DIFFERENT CLIENTS
SO- CALLING IN SUPPORT ON AND I
FEEL I'VE BEEN SEVENTY FIVE FOR
ANIMAL DEFENSE FUND. AND THEN
CALLING SUPPORT CURRENT AT THE
KENNEDY. FOR CALIFORNIA YIMBY
HABITAT WE NEED A CALIFORNIA
AND A THREE PIECE COLLECTION
WHICH INCLUDES ASSET FOUNDATION
TMG PARTNERS. AND YEAH YEAH.
NEXT WE WILL TURN TO LINE UP
SIX SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS BACK ALLEYS THAT ARE
REPRESENTING AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
IN SPPORT OF S. B. TWELVE FIVE
SEVEN DORADO AND SB NINE SEVEN
THREE JACKSON THANK YOU.
ANDECHS WE WILL TURN TO LINE OF
SIX EIGHT PLEASE CONTACT. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
AMERICA COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
JACKIE HUANG I AM A PROUD
SPONSOR- SB FOURTEEN A LOT NINE
ALONGSIDE WITH TIPPING POINT
COMMUNITY AT ALL OF THE
ECONOMIC SECURITY SECURITY
PROJECT. AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF THAT BILL I AM ALSO AND THE
REST OF MY SUPPORT FOR SB
ELEVEN OH THREE ALONGSIDE MACOS
LAUNCHERS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
I'M PRETTY OPPORTUNITY YOUTH
NETWORK THANK YOU. AND NEXT WE
WILL TURN TO LINE UP SIX FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THAT THE PETER PAPADOPOULOS
WITH THE MISSION ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND WE ARE OPPOSED IN
LATIN AND DATACOM'S SENATE BILL
TEN EIGHTY FIVE. THANK YOU. TO
RETURN TO THE LINE OF SIX ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM SPEAKER THE BETTER CHANCE
OF BRIAN DAHLE WORKING WITH THE
CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY. AND NONPROFIT
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATION
HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS AND
SUPPORTERS IN CALIFORNIA
SPEAKING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
S. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE STERN
AND WILDLIFE TREE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANNEX WE TURN THE
LIGHT OF FIVE EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MADAM CHAIR
COMMITTEE CATHERINE BOARD WITH
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON
REGISTER IN OUR SUPPORT FOR
SENATE BILL FIVE NINE SIX BY
SENATOR STERN. NEXT WE TURN THE
LIGHT ON FIVE SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
SABRINA FORTE FROM THE YOUTH
LAW CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB NINE TWELVE THE FOX DURING
CONNECTION BACK THANK YOU. NEXT
WE TURN TO LIGHT UP STICKS OUT
THAT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF HIS GAME
IN THE HONOR ON BEHALF OF
CONSUMER REPORTS IN SUPPORT OF
SB ELEVEN THIRTY THANK YOU
NEXT WE TURN TO LINE UP FOR TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SURE NUMBER
CATALINA SANCHEZ THE CORBIN AND
KINDER- REGISTERING SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA TAX
REFORM ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF SB NINE SEVEN Q. AND ON AT
THE ELEVEN THIRTY ON BEHALF OF
OUR CO SPONSORS AND INSTRUCT
THE PORT BY ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION AND COMMONSENSE.
THANK YOU. I'D LIKE TO TURN THE
LIGHT OF SEVEN ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS CARLA
GOMES YEAH YEAH IT WENT
DIRECTOR WITH THE LOTUS WHAT
THE FOUNDATION THAT REGISTERING
STRONG SUPPORT FOR SB TWELVE
FIFTY SEVEN TO APPLE'S SPELL.
S. B. FOURTEEN OH NINE YEP
THANK. N. BE JUST A MOMENT
PLEASE. PLEASE PRESS ONE PRESS
ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE TO QUEUE UP.
THE SENATE. WAS I DO HAVE SOME
OTHER ACTIVITY OUR NEXT WE TURN
TO LINE OF SEVEN EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS KEVIN
AND CONFERENCE COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
HEADQUARTERED SB FOURTEEN OH
NINE. SB TEN SIXTY FIVE S. B.
ELEVEN OH THREE ASK THE SEVEN
TO NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ADEX RETURNED TO LINE UP SEVEN
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AS I PONDER
TRICKLING IN EARLIER MY NAME'S
CARL ARLENE ELLIS I WITH THE
SOUTH SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA
RIFLE AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION
THE NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION
INTERNATIONAL DEFENSIVE PISTOL
ASSOCIATION THE SACRAMENTO
DEFENSE OFFICIAL SHOOTERS AND
THEY TOLD HIM SHOOTING CLUB.
NOT FIVE MILLION. WE OPPOSE SB
ELEVEN SEVEN FIVE AND S. B.
NINE FOURTEEN THANK YO THANK
YOU. NEXT RETURN TO THE LINE OF
THREE EIGHT PLEASE CONTACT.
NINE THREE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES SIR MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS BOB NAYLOR
REPRESENTING FIELD SEVEN
COMPANY A CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
AND STRONG SUPPORTER OF
CALIFORNIA YIMBY SUPPORTING S.
B. TEN EIGHTY FIVE N. S. B.
ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
I'D LIKE TO TURN THE LIGHT OF
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS RENEE ROWLAND
SHARE OF POP PACKED. WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY
FIVE AM EASTERN I DON'T KNOW IF
SB FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN ISN'T
SUSPENSE BY MINING BUT WE ARE
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
EIGHTY SEVEN. THANK YOU. I'D
LIKE TO TURN THE LIGHT OUT
EIGHT ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. TIM
JACKMAN RESIDENTS OF LOS
ANGELES IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
FIFTY ONE ONE SEVEN FIVE THANK
YOU. THE NEXT RICHARD KLEIN OF
EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
DIDN'T HAVE CONTRIBUTED IN THE
CITY OF REPLICATING IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL FOURTEEN FORTY ONE
THANK YOU. RETURN TO THE LINE
OF EIGHT FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE TO
RIGHT RIGHT THE L. A. COUNTY
BUSINESS FEDERATION IN SUPPORT
OF SB SEVEN NINE FIVE. NEXT WE
TURN TO LINE OF SEVEN NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH MY NAME
IS MARK CARMAX AND I WANT TO
SUPPORT S. B. EIGHT THREE
CERTIFIED PEER SPECIALIST BILL
AND- THE ORGANIZATION THAT I AM
PART OF THIS PROJECT RETURN
PEER SUPPORT NETWORK. AND THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY CLIENT
COALITION. AND NEXT RETURN TO
THE LINEUP EIGHT ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS JERRY BROWN
AGAIN- PRESIDENT OF SENDING
COUNTY WILDLIFE FEDERATION
CALLING TO OPPOSE SB NINE ONE
TWO. THANK YOU. NEXT RETURNED
TO THE LINEUP EIGHT FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS HEATHER STUDENT
ORGANIZER WITH THE MARTIN
LUTHER KING JUNIOR FREEDOM
CENTER OAKLAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF S. B. ELEVEN OH
THREE THANK YOU. I'D LIKE
RETURNED TO THE LINEUP EIGHTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT THE FATHR LOOK
AT THAT OPEN FROM BAFTA UP
OPPOSING SB KENNEDY. TO NINETY
THANK YOU. NEXT WE TURN TO LINE
OF SEVEN FIVE PLEASE CONTACT.
LIVE SEVENTY FIVE HEADS DROPPED
SO NEXT WE WILL TURN TO THE
LINE OF FIVE SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SAMMY MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA ON THEIR
OF FIFTY SEVEN FOUR ONE IN
SUPPORT. NEXT WE TURN TO THE
LIGHT AT EIGHT SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IT IS DIED DURING BATTLE
FROM THE SOUTH SACRAMENTO
CHAPTER OF THE EUROPEAN A IN
STRONG OPPOSITION OF SB. NINE
NINE FOURTEEN S. B. ELEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE THANK YOU. NEXT WE
TURNTO LINE UP NINE ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS IS DAVID JONES
ABOUT THE CITY BURBANK IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN NINETY FIVE
OPPOSITION TO SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE FOUR OF FORTY. FORTY ONE.
ORDER SB TEN EIGHTY FIVE THANK
YOU. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
FURTHER CRAWLERS IN Q. THAT'S-
THE COMPLETE SILVA SORRY. THAT
I BELIEVE IS WITH NOBODY ELSE
AGAIN AT OUTSIDE NOBODY ELSE
LEFT TO TESTIFY IN THE GALLERY
AND NOBODY ON THE PHONES THAT
COMPLETES OUR ENTIRE HEARING A
LITTLE DISJOINTED I AM SORRY OF
TODAY'S ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR PLAYING.